ever since his very first LCS split
there's never been a doubt that bjergsen
was destined for greatness me just about
coming in for gifting her copenhagen
wolves are going to push through here
pick up that first big thing he's a
prodigy who has forged his own path
through the world of League of Legends
to become not only one of league's most
decorated and celebrated players but
quite possibly the best Western player
of all time
that path hasn't always been easy
there's been plenty of risk defeat and
disappointment along the way but
champions like bjergsen
are forged by hardship this is his story
soren Bjork Sandburg was born on
February 21st 1996 in a small town in
the Jutland region of Denmark as a small
a skinny child he was often viciously
bullied by his classmates leading to
isolation and depression in the
beginning I mostly got bullied for
things like being skinny and like
playing a lot of video games the
bullying became very physical like I
would come back with like bruises and
marks I would come back like bleeding
some days we became bjergsen's fortress
and as his skills grew he climbed the
ranked ladder which gained him
significant attention from the high e
low e leaks I started like playing
against new professional players and I'd
seen them going to tournaments and I
started talking to some of them and they
would compliment me to be like oh wait
really you're like 15 16 years old
that's really impressive in an
interesting twist of history
bjergsen gained even more attention from
the community when he was asked to
substitute for Team solomid Andy
Reginald in during their match versus
TMC gaming in the online Corsair
Vengeance Cup Dylan live Yaya will
finally finish him off as cannibal I've
been in October of 2012 he was picked up
by the Danish organization copenhagen
wolves set to make his big land debut at
Dreamhack winter 2012 he then joined
copenhagen wolves and i'm like we're
going to cream mac and you're coming
with us and he's like no I'm not going
there's no way you're backing down from
this everything is sorted everyone is
waiting for you to come and you're going
to enjoy it when the dust settled the
Wolves had made it to the semi-finals
before losing to a no to counter logic
gaming EU a top four finish would earn
them a shot at a spot in the first-ever
split of the EU LCS ring and an
unexpected goodbye preparing a close
with Zod who take the Nexus make the
theory to zero and a balance of my
fnatic in our grad fun
good enough to get their shot at the LCS
but they would have to do it without
their new mid laner due to an age
restriction
bjergsen was forced to sit at home as
his team buckled down the copenhagen
wolves had a 16 year old AP mid player
called bjergsen who wasn't able to play
with him in this tournament though blow
to the team for sure they asked me if I
could play for them I don't have a key
right now I for primal thankfully
countered stepping in to fill the void
didn't present the Wolves from pulling
it off and they defeated millenium at
UNO to qualify the malady Nexus is
explode and it's going to be the
copenhagen wolf making it into c that's
right especially buritan didn't think
the team expected to get there and even
before the game they didn't expect that
they would be able to win so he didn't
think we would make it he said if we
were going to go against millenium we
would get our ass kicked so Gregson [ __ ]
you as the LCS season began bjergsen had
to watch as his team was smashed for the
first two weeks of the split going oh
and five but then before week three
bjergsen turned 17 and was allowed to
play once again there was a theme called
copenhagen old-time that was doing
really bad
9 as soon as your son entered his team
you could see the directivity moment
there looks plenty and the split was
staggering with Pearson leading the
charge the Wolves began to put some wins
on the board as the week's went on more
and more fans became hype for be
Erickson's obvious talents however for
an isolated anxious kid from Denmark it
was all a bit much to handle and the
change couldn't happen overnight
he often refused interviews and shied
away from the spotlight all while on the
rift
he continued to blow people away on
picks such as said Twisted Fate and his
signature syndra but over time the
loving fans supportive staff and his
fellow players surrounding the EU LCS
slowly broke bjergsen out of his shell
the Wolves ultimately finished 5th
overall in the spring of 2013 and were
knocked out of the playoffs in the first
round - and won by evil geniuses the
copenhagen wolves got just simply
spectators right now as are the rest of
us as evil geniuses take the base of the
copenhagen wolves there will be eg
facing fnatic in the semi final after
wreak Walla fiying for the summer split
with ease
bjergsen and the rest of the wolves were
transferred to ninjas and pajamas for
whom they would play the summer split
the teams that I have been in in
Copenhagen wolves ni p I never really
felt safe or I didn't feel like this
roster was a structured ni p suffered
from roster issues and inconsistency
that saw them once again finished 5th
then sent packing from the playoffs in
the first round this time to know by
gambit vengeance will it get you the
diamond though he just eats the pup
anyway he's got the guardian angel role
that comes out the Nexus 3 will go down
its
we came in that will be facing 11 dogs
in the semi-finals that'll feed that
needs adequate Jabba's are gonna face it
alternates to follow heading into the
offseason the Lee community was abuzz
over bjergsen it was clear to everyone
he was a rare talent a dominant 1v1
laner capable of single-handedly
carrying games Pearson then made one of
the biggest Gamble's of his career he
moved to North America to join Team
solomid objection I read it in your
million good it up Proctor you it was a
massive risk not only would he be
stepping into the spotlight of one of
Enys most popular and historic teams he
would be tasked with replacing Reginald
the founder of the franchise in essence
the once shy and anxious mid laner had
to become the face of a franchise and
lead the team into a new era but no
changes that talked about more than TSM
signing of a former ni p starve Eriksson
to take over the mid lane from Reginald
and while moving almost halfway around
the world and adjusting to new teammate
can have its problems so far beer
tonight TSM things have been working out
ok making his TSM debut facing off
against his old region at Battle of the
Atlantic
Pearson dominated the lemondogs to lead
TSM to a to a no sweep of the EU
representative a completely different
start to this game but the same result
in the end of team solo they took back
the driver's seat
after a very formidable spark start from
lemon
but it just wasn't enough to zero yet
with beer to NASA helm TSM surged to a
twenty two and six record in the 2014
spring split however his presence wasn't
enough to push the team past their rival
cloud9 won the playoff title or you know
cloud nine go to end the series 3-0
they're going to take down the Nexus and
they're the North American champion
although TSM had to settle for second
place Peterson's baby split on TSM was
more than enough to earn him the
admiration of the North American players
and of course the fan that year was the
first time that both Europe and like the
world heard like who gives most of the
player depends like well he was capable
and all of a sudden crushing everyone
everyone was talking me up and hyping me
up and I really invited my ego so I just
didn't take everyone's criticism as
harshly as I should his stream exploded
in popularity and bjergsen continued to
grow a more open and confidence together
that's uh whoa
yeah the kid who ran away from
interviews was no more he had fully
embraced his role as the new face of TSM
sadly the loss in the finals was a blow
to be Ericsson after watching his Lane
opponent hai lead his team to victory
bjergsen began to recognize he needed to
level up his game losing to him was big
like oh I beat this guy in a while vs.
won but that doesn't matter
team game he was able to lead his team
to victory and I wasn't this big I read
he needed to become more than just a
star player but someone who could play a
team game and spread his individual
skill into other aspects of the game
those lessons in mind gherkin made good
on his potential in the summer of 2014
helping TSM recapture the NA LCS title
with a 3-2 win over 2014 North American
champion it was a monumental victory not
only returning TSM to their place atop 2
na LCS but cementing bjergsen status as
an elite threat this week there was one
player who stood above the rest and is
our playoff MVP from TSM it's Barracks
in with TSM s domestic win the next step
was for beer s'en to prove his mettle on
the international stage at Worlds 2014
he got his chance second suit the role
here
oh very low are finding infamous book
let's see what kind of abuse do any guy
here is joining it with the augment with
very low here gonna find the object in
the power blade while he was down
dyrus was able full damage even after
the wild quote misused through our team
and finally shall we automate his work
boy oh my god still going on morning he
gets it the prayer to work on a Mingo
that's what quick shot from Pearson they
are really heat things up with Pierson
impressing every step of the way TSM
made out of the group's before losing to
Samsung white three and one for members
doubt Justin doing what he can to stay
alive but it's not going to be enough
white bull takes out team solo the
quarterfinals however while TSM might
have faced an early exit from the events
Pearson had gone toe to toe with some
serious competition and shown he could
compete next up was another
international test at IEM San Jose many
predicted and easy road to the finals
for TSM despite new jungler Santorin
joining the ranks but things didn't
exactly go according to plan
oh man I'll say on your power people
kills barracks in game yeah one more
also in fact all the queue will finish
him off and power reveal meanwhile
taking a lot of damage will partly we'll
get the coolers back this is our Twisted
Fate half an hour Aviva Leslie using his
ultimate that after good howling gales
coming to keep is going to turn around
power of evil comes back in but he's
exhausted it silent the weather bird
soggy
they managed to get that kill power of
evil divided up the other side Kiki
blesses it very thoroughly so Foreman as
well and now farthing comes in more can
they get here see it wants to get into
the pipeline
if only look boy left alive he'll be
closed down power of evil should be able
to finish before us and there it is and
it is we see bjergsen amid trying to
play one of the safest champions and
actually getting as I said Bronk tout by
power of evil there yeah that is another
thing to know you know even though you
have two new it's not immediately gone
big lane on in gypsum going down lonely
and seek anymore to use the fire
would it be a lot sake of ignite front
power of evil it was one of the few
times that bjergsen specifically was so
brutally outplayed in the laning phase
one of the strongest parts of his game
just those two games against our evil
men they still put mental just tons of
skill coming out of power of evil had
those insane solo kills got the help he
needed from the jungle and I mean
skilled smart - I mean he knows how to
get fed fast you just go to the Burger
King you know
thankfully the beatdown didn't hold
bjergsen back they roared into the 2015
spring split firing on all cylinders I
contend hitting on his turret for dog
vomit out that's going to be it Santora
not even needed for time Kali's
roosevelt good boo powers is the flash
of the saga couch will still going
though force the passive but he's a
turret reiji's got to be careful here's
against the kill left boys won it away
from dead but Nocturne couldn't click on
it as the best team in na halfway
through the split TSM received an invite
to the IEM World Championship in
Katowice ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the Intel Extreme Masters whoa
championship there they made history one
silly looking to try and get him all
they're going to go for a little nothing
getting low but he will flash away from
that factory picks up the rampage
very both on the backside of the mystic
will drop here finally and are falling
down almost instantly they try for long
laughing game the Sun comes in future
will be popped and that in the a-15
solomid and with 20 seconds left on the
clock they are going to put straight
through that lasted world champion team
solomid were the first team from North
America to win a major international
competition which a Korean team attended
for four years while their path was made
significantly easier by the GE Tigers
stunning elimination at the hands of
team we TSM's victory at IEM is still a
significant achievement surprisingly
well TSM carried their momentum back
home closing out the regular season and
first to once again secure the NA LCS
title over game is here we go all the
over engage in indeed elimination on the
outside and gets bounced iris he wanted
dives in on the balls of sanguine pool
sees him just the last second so what we
want to pierce it in hinds is the white
goes down behind alive and Pearson dies
to the turret turtle now is the focus to
depth charge into anger talks they lock
him down with the passive but he is
hopping around way too much on Callisto
could he be coming up with a fender five
days on the part in the water till once
again to come up with Team solomid
Seminole win on the North American
spring split and they will do it once
again the consecutive wins for Team
solomid the nexus ball and team solomid
on the 2015 North American League of
Legends Championship Series spring split
champion
bjergsen was named the NA LCS split MVP
for the second time the earth in getting
the Most Valuable Player Award here for
the spring play by this point
bjergsen had won two domestic titles -
na LCS MVP awards a significant
international tournament and was still
considered by most to be the best mid
laner not only in na but the West Maple
don't sing a death mountainside really
well played abroad bewbs and maybe a
miss flavor from maple side of me
despite their dominant playoff
performance TSM was absolutely crushed
at the first-ever midseason Invitational
going 1 in 4 in the group stage
I guess wildturtle backing off now is
coral jumps in now Oh Corki in trouble
gets taken down and now the Nexus
finally focused 27 kills in 25 minutes
for EDG as they take the game over TSM
it's over back in the LCS a few weeks
later things didn't go much better
while bjergsen still led by example with
impressive play they faltered in the
back half of the summer split fans
largely pointed the finger towards wild
turtles lackluster performance and it
was clear
TSM lacked in other areas as well TSM
limped into the playoffs and 5th but in
typical TSM style when playoffs rolled
around the team came alive right now
this has to just be deterring Team
solomid but not at all they actually put
themselves in a bad spot gravity goes
down now trying to deter Team solomid
for more Syrus North out of the perfect
time once again it's gonna be an eighth
under granny and team solomid start to
lock this one down 22 minutes in it mean
solomid running down the track dyrus in
front of the trains who also playoff and
team solomid are going to take down
gravity three to one in the quarterfinal
soon as you get this cutler op2 caught
out meaning they go down the fire here
that'll be a lot of hits dominate if
we're going to bodyslam it they didn't
expect this much pressure quick for the
bot lane without them being able to
answer now they've approached the fight
somebody getting hit up left boy looking
to hit the perfect truck here he gets it
on to dominate good patience now they're
on to a specialist Kirsten just thrown
out glitter everywhere they're able to
pick up three that one turtle looking to
go around the Nexus but they stay
focused get it down on the priority
target 50 goals going into Wilder Lane
they take this down and team solomid
take the semifinal series to face
counter logic gaming as they take out
key with TSM unseeded gravity then
smashed the first place Team Liquid
three and one but even their playoff
buff wasn't enough to help TSM pass
counter logic gaming who won their first
LCS title in a sweep your logic gaming
bye
every season since there has been one
and now taking down Team solomid Madison
Square Garden to be your 2015 let's camp
is even with CLG crowned as the new na
LCS champs TSM and bjergsen headed to
worlds 2015 in an attempt to repeat
their success from 2014 one of these
things with our team is that we fall
apart when we are in the moment
allocations and it takes us too long to
figure out like what to do when
something feels uncomfortable
realistically we just do well this this
week and we have one more week to script
and we just like clear up like all the
small mistakes we can really well get
out of groups so let's just focus on
them one at a time
Pearson could do nothing as TSM was
ruled out of the tournament with only a
single win to their credit 36 minutes in
LGD was able to rout team solomid in
their competition find their way to the
Nexus and take down
TSM getting knocked out really so to be
honest I had really high expectations
for our team or at least expectations to
get out of groups because we managed to
do that last year and I don't want to
play professionally for another year and
feel like I can't accomplish the same
thing or somehow got worse or we can
perform the same way as a team so that
was a big disappointment to me the loss
of their na LCS title combined with the
SmackDown at Worlds called for major
changes in TSM everything that's there
it's been done and now it's time to open
a new book right now my story ends here
but I have nothing but gratitude for you
guys and I wish the best of luck my
teammates get you sure dyrus retired in
an emotional interview while wildturtle
Santorin and lustboy all left the squad
regardless of all these were also
changes and people retiring and not
being into you anymore I'm still really
excited to play for TSM next season that
we are hopefully going to pick up new
players that are really hungry that want
to learn first and foremost was double
lifts who joined the team only hours
after the conclusion of the World
Championship in a dramatic reveal
doublelift and starting today I'll be a
part of TSM with New York Sims carry
power backed up by double lips fans were
already frothing at the mouth for TSM
future
add to the mix be rickson's former
copenhagen wolves teammate Spence Caron
and the breakout star hunter and TSM was
already looking back the only question
mark was the support role with the team
already full to bursting with mechanical
talent TSM needed an experienced leader
and so TSM brought in yellow star as the
starting support hoping his veteran
status would help balance the needs of
the team star carries and give a
definite voice to the team and the whole
thought one that with yellow star coming
in I could kind of really focus on my
individual plan kind of the
communication around my role and I
didn't have to micromanage or kind of
double-check that everyone is doing a
job all at the same time because that's
what he's known for
TSM struggled out of the gates with
inconsistent results throughout the
front half of a split the clashing egos
of bjergsen double lift and yellow star
caused tension in the team and it showed
in the results it's almost like it's
almost like playing saw like you I mean
I don't want to like bash but our
communication is really just at that
like super basic level at the moment
where it's like what's next what's next
what's next GSM slid all the way into 6
to close the split but then it was
playoff time and poor season be damned
the buff was in order once again yeah
bruh just could be it a quarterfinal
matchup that had cloud 9 winning the
first game rush trying to prevent the
sweep TSM coming back strong though
three consistent games in a row and a
bloody bloody fourth game that they made
to take
thirty minutes into the game team
solomid takes a quarterfinal match
against cloud i despite entering week
TSM defeated cloud nine and decimated
immortals before falling to CLG again
this time three in two and throughout
the entire series I noticed that CLG
just had a much cleaner macro game than
TSM even the games of TSM won it was
usually through brute forcing teamfights
and in CLG game it was usually clip Bush
turret pressure and then sometimes they
would team by just like in that last
game how they ended up closing is out so
CLG look more diverse the strategies
that they're able to bring to the table
and their macro game is just cleaner
while their plans performance might have
been better the yellow star experiment
was a failure
TSM decided to bring in rookie player
bio frost to round out the team is
ability to lead macro discussion or just
make calls in general is extremely
limited like you understand them he's a
solo key player so he doesn't really
understand the game at a high level
yellow stars departure sabe Erikson once
again shouldering the shotcalling
responsibilities vacated he accepted the
burden that comes with being both star
player and team leader so it's been
pretty much all the time I have in
between the games and I'm playing
watching my own replays trying to be
really self-critical and just looking at
every little thing I do and seeing if it
can be optimized tsm's only series loss
for the entire 2016 summer split was a
dramatic upset at the hands of Phoenix 1
he's only got 3 minions
oh my god he's actually doing no there's
been another mini wave coming in he
probably the ghostly he's actually going
for the end cuz he has he'll get back in
time I don't think they realized what's
happening rushing down a teleporting are
you late it's too late it's gonna go
down for keeping up the head so Mac gets
the kill regards on the Nexus I could
not believe it at the end what they're
able to spoil TS devil so fast Midori
I'm not
kill ball well - n7 Phoenix was defeat
TSM after two playoff losses at the
hands of CLG this time Pearson and TSM
would not be denied another title they
crushed CLG three and OH before smashing
c-93 and won in the final way as TSM
semester self as the most dominant
organization North American League of
Legends and when their fourth North
American Championship incredible moment
for these guys
judge how much indeed to the
disappointment last year in Vegas and
now finally victory is there the winning
women feel really good I think the best
part about kind of winning is that to be
able to win the finals you always have
to win as a team and this was one of
those moments where I felt like it was
not communicate I didn't even feel like
I played particularly well but I feel
like you know my team really carried me
and kind of as a team we want by the end
of the split
bjergsen had a mass 11 player of the
game Awards and was named the NA LCS MVP
for the summer season for an astonishing
third time the Ericsson
this is actually your third time winning
the MVP award no one else in North
America is wanted more than one what
does that mean to you obviously means a
lot I think this year it means more than
ever because na has a strong stronger
and stronger each foot and this season I
think na has the strongest individual
players that they ever had so I honestly
didn't expect to win this award today
and be here so I'm very happy another na
LCS title meant another trip to Worlds
for TSM and bjergsen sadly it was a
heartbreaker and they failed to make it
out of groups with a final game loss to
Royal never give up
goes down royal never give up look at
them the sights of the Nexus Suzy
getting supper for the Nexus is going
down Akeem Sol amazed at their hearts
their dreams
done royal high for the Chicago while
domestic success and I am glory had been
his bjergsen had once again failed to go
deep at a world championship the NA LCS
and Western fans Europe and North
America joined behind TSM hey we all did
unfortunately they didn't show up in
groups yeah we all did I mean TSM this
year with such a powerhouse such a
quality team you could see the yolks and
cents Karen to the very end we're trying
to battle their way out of that one
you hate to think oh really for all the
effort he had put into becoming the
player and the leader TSM had required
it was a crushing results every single
time when I had to be clutch I failed
every time every cluster I felt things
weren't going to get any easier though
doublelift opted to take some time off
and wildturtle returned to the team
applying get more pressure to the
Eriksson to carry his team thankfully
another turn of the calendar saw TSM
once again returned to the top of the NA
pile finishing the spring split in first
place and defeating p1 and c9 three and
two and closer series to claim the title
[Applause]
once again na LCS champions clouds eyes
what
for the second time team solomid had
earned the right to represent na at the
midseason Invitational but they failed
to make an impact on the international
stage yet again with the playful picked
up looking for the urchin strike get
against Jared mm diesel Achilles free
Frankie flashes forward the other seven
early to care about them looking for the
killed at the flats walls chase down
turtle Bernie and the next man destroy
any sense
take the Nexus turret take the Nexus and
flash wolves up boys let's go be final
it does really start being an ace
representative and not being able to do
well on seeing comments like Oh Syl ji
did so much better or aw man c9 we've
done so much better in their place but
you know we also mean to beat out those
teams because we were the better team
back in North America it was business as
usual for Team solomid with double lift
back at ad carry and challenging for the
top of the table
TSM defended North American honor at the
first riff rivals smashing unicorns of
love three no in the grand finals the
Nexus turrets are falling the first is a
victim to parent empowered minions
they've got to deal with stomach suggest
it's like just being yeah double its
security eight as a necessary slowly
take it down up they've got another
challenger to approach but it's just the
support yeah there's too many many is
too much damage and on this day your
wrist rival champion he is empty clay
and a greater than EU the wind banished
some of the bad taste left from the
still recent MSI
today Pearson is still a powerhouse who
has done whatever it took to become a
champion but he's not quite done setting
records just the other day he became the
first na LCS mid laner to reach 1,000
career kills Mary law the backsides
Acadian he goes down the far parent does
he is not a god here's the objective
Pearson getting one of these tails
Pearson getting a second kill 1,000
pills for Pearson and they get the bear
in four members of boxer town TSM
running strong that's the a from mm I'm
in a thousand and nine kills does it
feel as great as your first one I mean
it feels pretty good
I actually I realize I got over a
thousand kills actually called months
ago he counted my kills in Europe when I
played me he else yes but reaching this
muscle just in na LCS obviously feels
pretty good while he's yet to have the
deep run at world he sure come a heck of
a long way from the kid who ran away
from interviews and used the league to
escape bullying like we said from the
very first split there was no doubt
Pearson was destined for greatness and
he's earned it every step of the way
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]